so bad at this so the options are jackin
the-box Burger King Wendy's McDonald's
chick-fil-a and in and out a fast-food
unfortunately all the time I love fast
food and definitely did get me through
college
I need best foods for ethically I'm not
like a fast food connoisseur I think
I'll be pretty decent at it but there
are a lot of options here I was younger
I never thought fast food was gonna ever
actually make me feel sick now it does
let's see number one we have yeah this
is a larger size button it smells like
wheat beer so this bun
Oh actually this looks like a big match
button but it's maybe a little too big
for it if it was a Big Mac that would be
at third fun unless you're tricking it
it's weird eating the bread without the
actual sandwich I think this is a Wooper
it smells like barbecue it looks like
the Burger King quacks like a Burger
King parking so the sesame seeds are
definitely get away this is a whopper
from Burger King it's either McDonald's
or Burger King McDonald's
let me say this is Burger King but I
think sesame seeds is the McDonald's
it's indicative of Mik I'm gonna say
McDonald's
but ooh okay I don't think I recognize
it look at that that's a simple bun oh
this could be McDonald's too they have
two kinds of bread it tasted very plain
it tastes almost perfect yeah it
definitely really Drive it's toasted so
that's good this is more the size I
would expect from like a McDonald's or
something McDonald's this is McDonald's
for sure I know I know this bun plastic
blade blend it in and out I'm gonna go
with McDonald's one certainly not
chick-fil-a that's gonna be the easiest
one I think well no this could be
chick-fil-a [ __ ] I wanna say this is
chick-fil-a it for now no no no Burger
King has the stuff on it this is Burger
King this is McDonald's
wait yeah yeah I'm surprisingly good at
this I think oh [ __ ] that's the
identical well this is harder than I
thought it was going to be
and I see now I think I'm wrong oh wow
his buttons burnt
I had cranky I wouldn't eat this as
toast in the morning smells like a
blanket
I'm gonna guess jack-in-the-box that's a
good quality bun I'm gonna say this is
in a no I'm gonna go with a chick-fil-a
on this one
Wendy's was like Wonder Bread jacket ah
check my lair oh my god I'm so good at
this there's no ending out here right
this isn't in it oh man these are really
tough it's oily I don't recognize a
shiny top of the bun this feels
artisanal I just like that word cut is
no this one actually tastes a little bit
better I think since they're on that new
health cake this is probably a new
mcdonalds bun yep definitely tastes like
McDonald this will like like fancy like
chick-fil-a this feels like when do you
decorate is this in and out I'm gonna
guess this one's in and out so I'm gonna
say this is Wendy I'm getting in and out
bud I say in and out I think that
glisten is from Jack in the Box this is
so much fun
Wow oh god are you kidding me fully crap
they all look the same
I'm losing my confidence as I work my
way to the hip it also feels nice
putting bread against your face
that's a Whitney's button hey Wendy's
way too much cuz I just opened it oh my
oh yeah this is Wendy's definitely
actually kind of chick my industrial
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a Wendy's biz
McDonald's finds you a double
cheeseburger beyond that I just had in
and out this weekend
this is in and out I think I already
guessed McDonald's but now I'm thinking
I should have saved McDonald's or later
I'm gonna go with Jack Jack in a box I'm
gonna say this is Jack in the Box
disturbingly similar to McDonald's so I
could be wrong here oh this one looks so
good you made me think that they're all
gonna be different cuz of that one oh
this smells like so real and authentic
oh my god it's soft it's lightly toasted
not too rough like that one by process
of elimination then this must be Wendy's
I really don't know I mean I guess in
and out so I have to hop
I've really got lost back this is the
one that I feel like lease familiar with
hate Wendy's way too much cuz I just
open it I'm like yeah this is Wendy's
definitely this is you know I'm right I
feel so confident I'm gonna say this is
chick-fil-a
I lose my confidence here they're in and
out so there's Wendy's when he's left
that's not Wendy's this is in and out
this is chick-fil-a it makes you think
of how much we like take bread for
granted when you're eating a burger or
sandwich because it's like you don't
care it's all about the meat out of six
I think I got one maybe two right I feel
like I'm changing my mind
[Music]
seriously wow this is crazy because like
I never thought I would confuse
McDonald's with chick-fil-a wow I feel
so bad for getting Wendy's wrong
I mean McDonald's come from me - but
like McDonald's like my side shake so Oh
what Wendy's was so good
I don't eat at Wendy's maybe I should
this was probably the hardest thing I've
ever done
final verdict this is still Burger King
I'm saying this is very thing
McDonald's chick-fil-a jack-in-the-box
what's left Wendy's and in and out
Wendy's really that's Wendy's me
[Music]